Colet rings a few bells writer Parris
fuzzy hair cats fuzzy hairs hers not the
cats so what cried out to you to say we
have to make a film about this would
this woman who's known but not so known
that's right her story's well-known
inside France internationally it's not
so well known of course she she has her
very devoted fans but my co-writer and
co-director and late husband Richard
Glasser was an avid reader and he just
started reading a lot of Colette around
1999 so a long time ago he was you know
reading the biographies and reading the
novels and he said there's a movie in
here she's just this incredible
personality the decisions she takes a
certain junctures in her life no one
else would take she's unique she's a
trailblazer it's astonishing what she
did and I started reading as well and we
decided the first marriage to Willie
Gautier Vilar's was the natural
narrative to see her formation as an
artist but we were sure to include the
fuzzy hair and the cats and oh yeah
everybody would be looking for the fuzzy
hair and the cats so and and Christine
for you I mean get at killer films
you've done some extraordinary things
with still Alice and boys don't cry and
I think carol was one of yours so what
here is a figure of history not of
fiction who wrote fiction herself and
for you to take this and undertake this
project what was it about it that
appealed so much to you well first I
just want to say my co-producer should
be up here Pam Koffler but she lost her
voice and and so we're celebrating a
film about a woman finding her voice the
producer who has lost her voice so I but
you know I think you know we really
gravitate towards true life stories
especially ones that seem to I don't
seem to sort of stick in your teeth like
this is a story that years later for
myriad reasons and I think you know it's
part of what wash was saying how
it was something that that he and
Richard kept going back to it feels like
it it comes around again and the
zeitgeist and feels incredibly relevant
and those are the kind of stories we
just love to celebrate within the same
calendar year we have this film and the
wife which is about another woman whose
literary identity was being stolen by a
man so clearly these stories are coming
to the fore at a time when people are
willing to hear them that's right I
think this story could be told a
thousand times every day many friends
who I've talked to about Colette say
yeah you know sometimes when I'm in a
meeting and I come up with an idea and
everyone ignores me and then five
minutes later my boss comes up with the
same idea and gets full credit for it
and I think there's something about you
know the male power structure that is
now sort of accommodating women's voices
more but there's still so much further
to go in getting you know gender
equality in the workplace and to get
women's voices heard in the arts and
entertainment industries Stephen you
broke into movies taking tickets at a
theater in Islington so maybe you have a
bit of a story to tell but an idea about
what appealed to you about this project
well I also have to say talking about
male structures my producing partner
Elizabeth couldn't be here either
and so I have to speak on slightly on
her behalf which feels unfair given that
the film we've just watched I'm not sure
what the question was what appeal well I
think well peel to Bertha's about the
script was that it was a very modern
story we we really felt the behavior of
Willie was something that as you've said
you see all the time in modern day life
not something that's it felt historical
and we felt the washes amazing script
really bucked the trend of costume
dramas I don't think any of us were I
mean neither Elizabeth and I were very
keen to make a costume drama as such but
the I think it was really the moment in
the script when they started to brand
when collette and Willi decided to brand
their character that claudia we Clawdeen
sorry we really thought wow this is this
is not something we've really seen
before on the screen this is this is
something that is a sort of 20th century
phenomenon and this seemed to be the
beginning of something that we now take
for every day as norm you know that you
write a successful book you haven't
theater production you have soap you
have cigarettes this was I think there's
been of a revelation for both of us so
we had made as you mentioned before
Carol with killer films and it was Pam
and Christine who sent us the script
looking for a European partner so we
jumped on it immediately and we loved
still Alice washes first movie so it was
a really very happy occasion for all of
us
I was quite as washed Walter Lee it was
a really tough production in terms of
putting all that money up on the screen
doll the little money that we had
Christine about that lavish money that
you didn't have a lot of this was shot
in Budapest was that because of the
architecture or the tax credits or both
I think both I mean we really Budapest
was was an extraordinary place to shoot
and the locations I mean wasn't only
Budapest we also we did one day in Paris
and how many days in the UK not a week I
think in the UK so but Budapest brought
so much to to the screen you think the
French will be unhappy that it's so far
that hasn't been the case I mean the
true test we always felt is like showing
it to a French audience and seeing if it
feels like Paris Budapest actually
copied Paris stylistically especially in
the late 19th century in Paris was the
most fashionable city in Europe Budapest
has its own Sean's ELISA I called and
Russia and they have a Moulin Rouge in
Budapest that was copied from the
original Parisian Moulin Rouge boarded
up throughout the common issues and has
only just been reopened and we got to
shoot there and fortuitously it's
actually more like the original Moulin
Rouge than the one that's now in Paris
because it was boarded up first so yeah
they didn't refurbish it it just stayed
with the original ornamentation and
color scheme and everything looks so
that really set the stage for shooting
what a discovery now yeah well one of
the real things that we as producers
we're discovering all the time is that
actually the location if you're making a
period film the location that the film
is set is not necessarily the best place
to shoot it so the last two films for
instance we've done set in London we
shot one in Leeds and one in Swansea so
it's not unusual
your hometown Leeds right that's right
that's correct he's interested oh I was
just gonna say it's interesting like so
many period pieces were in one beautiful
room and Colette was a very kinetic
person so we were always looking for or
where's the staircase is coming down
where's the corridor she's going into
how can she move through this scene the
camera always follows her so even though
Willie's dominating her using up all the
oxygen she's controlling the narrative
even when she's you know very young and
inexperienced but we had to have this
ability and we found this in Budapest to
go from room to room to room and follow
her through that those spaces know what
about the casting decisions because
Colette had to be just right because
everyone who knows ever has an image of
her in her head so maybe all of you
would like to speak to that well some
people say was Kyra the first person you
thought of and I said well the script
was written in 2001 and Kyra was 14 so I
cannot claim that but seeing her early
work in Pride and Prejudice you saw this
incredibly talented actress who had this
kind of verbal dexterity and this sort
of laser beam coming out of her eyes as
she could just tear mr. Darcy apart so
even a number of years back Richard and
I thought well you know she could tear
Willie apart as she does in the last
scene of this film and when the film was
remounted after still Alice so it was
three years ago Kyra was the you know
natural person to go to because she has
this person like electricity she has a
dry wit she has a sensuality she has an
intelligence and I felt that between
Collett and Willie there should be like
a game of wits going on that they were
always entertaining each other with
their minds
and both Kira and Dominik have this
ability to be just very quick and very
sharp and and play you know sort of
tennis with each other with the dialogue
so you had to did you cast them together
because you had to see whether that
dynamic worked or no no we cast Kira
first and then we had to find a Willie
who matched Kira's sort of energy and
and you know you just get a feeling
sometimes for a pairing with the
chemistry or work in real life Willie
was 14 years older than Colette Dominic
is 14 years older than Kira and Dominic
also got that for the relationship to
work in a cinematic way it couldn't just
be they couldn't just be hating Willie
you have to understand why he got away
for so long with bad behavior and it's
because he's ability to be charming and
why she loved him to why she left him
yeah it's a love story and it's a story
of a mentor who's also an exploiter as
you worked on this this was and I hope
it's not too painful this is a project
of your late husband's as well and so
what what did you feel from him was his
part in this what he put in and what you
wanted it to be for his sake well yeah
this this was really Richards project
Richard wrote the first draft and we
worked on it together for so many years
we went to about 15 drafts together
about three title changes we made three
other movies in the time we were waiting
and wanting to make Colette and the last
of those were still Alice and Richard in
the last four years of his life had ALS
which is a terrible disease that
gradually paralyzes you during the
making of still as he was just typing
with one finger and by the time it was
up in the Academy Awards
we were watching from the ICU at scene
aside I seen a Sinai Hospital didn't
stop us celebrating we got some friends
to smuggle some champagne and when Julia
Angwin we really just cheered so loud
they thought there was a medical
emergency
people came like running and and
afterwards I asked him what he wanted to
do next and he was typing with his toe
by that point but he wrote Colette and
he passed away just two weeks after the
Academy Award but he got to see that you
know
a filmmaker who got to see that's
wonderful and when I came out of my
deepest grief and Pam and Christine are
also very good friends with Richard we
all knew what we had to do that we had
to make this film so making it was
actually when you're coming out of the
deepest grief you still need the
connection with the person by making
this film it it kept me connected to
Richard's creative it in his spirit and
you know sometimes when I was a little
stuck on the set I think what would
Richard do and I'd get the answer so I
think he was around it was great hearing
his words coming out of the mouths of
such wonderful actors won't you please
thank our panel